Speaker 1: We start today with President Joe
Biden's speech in Warsaw, Poland.
This is a speech that the president gave after
his visit to Ukraine.
This is a visit in general and also in particular,
a speech that has really exposed the worst
of the worst of the authoritarian right wing
in the United States.
And one of the fascinating things as we're
going to look at some clips here of this speech
that President Biden gave, President Biden
focused in on a criticism of autocrats and
authoritarians overtly.
He's talking about Vladimir Putin.
But when you listen to the criticism, this
would just as accurately apply to the authoritarian,
autocratic, dictatorial wannabe MAGA, right,
of the United States.
Joe Biden was super strong in this speech.
Let's take a look at this first section about
autocracy and the importance of opposing it
anywhere that we see it.
Speaker 2: President Putin's craven lusts
for land and power will fail, and the Ukrainian
people's love for their country will prevail.
Democracies of the world will stand guard
over freedom today, tomorrow, and forever.
So that's what is that's what's at stake here.
Freedom.
That's the message I kind of gave yesterday
directly to the people of Ukraine.
When President Zelensky said he came to the
United States in December, quote, He said,
This struggle will define the world and what
our children and grandchildren, how they live
and that their children and grandchildren.
He wasn't always speaking about the children
and grandchildren of Ukraine.
It was speaking about all of our children
and grandchildren, yours and mine.
We're seeing it again today with the people
of Poland and the people across Europe saw
for decades appetites of the autocrat cannot
be appeased.
They must be opposed.
Autocrats only understand one word.
No, no, no.
I know you will not take my country.
No, you will not take my freedom.
No, you will not take my future.
And I'll repeat tonight what I said last year.
The same place a dictator, venerable building
an empire will never be able to ease the people's
love of liberty.
Brutality will never grind down the will of
the free.
And Ukraine.
Ukraine will never be a victory for Russia.
Never.
Speaker 1: So one of Biden's strongest speeches
and of course, he doesn't write these.
He puts his touch on them, but he's not writing
these speeches.
But the message, as much as it here, is designed
for Putin, it could go for Orban, it could
go for Trump, it could go for the former Brazilian
president, Jair Bolsonaro.
All of these autocrats have this wannabe dictator
streak.
And what is stunning is that even though the
right has claimed a monopoly on freedom and
liberty in the United States for at this point
probably two decades, it is increasingly the
right that wants to restrict freedoms of all
sorts of kinds.
What can we teach?
What can we say?
What can social media companies do?
What can other private industries do?
What can people do in their bedroom?
What pronouns can people choose to be called?
But increasingly, it's the Democratic Party,
of which I am not a part.
As many of you know, I have no particular
concern with the Democratic Party, but this
happens to be a Democratic president who is
actually the one talking about freedom and
liberty in a more serious way.
Joe Biden continued and said that, well, let's
just listen.
He addressed the Ukrainian conflict specifically.
Speaker 2: In the United States, together
with our allies and partners, are going to
continue to have Ukraine's back as it defends
itself.
Next year, I will host every member of NATO
for our 2024 summit in the United States.
Together, we'll celebrate the 75th anniversary
of the strongest defensive alliance in the
history of the world, NATO's and.
And let there be no doubt the commitment of
the United States to our NATO alliance and
Article five is rock solid.
Speaker 1: So there can be reasonable and
spirited debate as to how large should the
American contribution to Ukraine be.
How long lasting should the commitment be?
And is it fair or reasonable for the United
States to be disproportionately supporting
Ukraine in comparison to other allied countries?
All of those are reasonable conversations.
But what Joe Biden distilled clearly in this
speech is something that it's shocking.
People still have to be reminded of it.
And I know they do, because Vladimir Putin
recently said in his address something along
the lines of the U.S. started this war, Ukraine
started this war.
It wasn't Russia who started the war.
Russia started the war.
This is a defensive situation for Ukraine.
And Joe Biden doing a good job of pointing
that out and then going further in terms of
what the U.S. and Western allies are seeking
and what they are not seeking.
Speaker 2: So tonight, I speak once more to
the people of Russia, the United States and
the nations of Europe.
Do not seek to control or destroy Russia.
The West was not plotting to attack Russia,
as Putin said today.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: And millions of Russian citizens
only want to live in peace with their neighbors
are not the enemy.
This war is never a necessity.
It's a tragedy.
President Putin chose this war.
Every day the war continues is his choice.
He could end the war with the world.
It's simple.
If Russia stopped embedded in Ukraine, it
would end the war.
If Ukraine stopped defending itself against
Russia, it would be the end of Ukraine.
That's why together, we're making sure Ukraine
can defend itself.
Speaker 1: And again, it is stunning that
this has to be repeated.
You can still make the case that despite it
being a defensive situation for Ukraine, the
U.S. is involvement should have limits.
That's a perfectly reasonable conversation
to have.
I don't know of anyone on the left who is
saying that these are unlimited blank checks
for the end of time.
That is not what I'm hearing anybody saying.
If somebody is saying that, please let me
know.
But the context and the circumstances in which
this is happening must be restated regularly
because there is a propaganda effort from
Putin and from others to pretend that the
circumstances are different.
Let's next talk about how this entire Ukraine
visit has broken the brains of many right
wingers.